how are you doing sir
i'm very well steve how are you doing
excellent uh
i want to ask the most important
question right at the beginning
okay did you think about return retiring
from the entire entertainment industry
after doing the paul mccartney
liverpool thing because how will it ever
get better than that
well i think you've got a very very good
point steve and
it does cross my mind um that that might
be the pinnacle of
uh human existence and i and
if i'm honest i'm really enjoying
something at the time i'm doing it so
i'm i struggle a lot with being
present in that moment thinking wow what
an amazing thing to be doing it's really
only if i look back
and think on you know holidays or trips
or anything like that or
anything i've done on the show i look
back and go wow there's nothing
that most being singing penny lane
down penny lane with paul mccartney
and going in the shops and the stores
and all those things like i
i've heard the phrase oh it's stopped
traffic before
i've never really seen it like i can't
tell you
there must have been 40 cars and not one
car horn beeping and also
what i thought was beautiful not one
person
asking like paul for a selfie they just
wanted to thank him and shake his hand
and go
thank you for everything you've given me
in my life
and yes i do feel like
it's just been a it just will all
forever be
a decline away from that moment
i watched that and was so i felt the
magic as i was watching it it meant a
lot to me and just i can't imagine
yeah you know like uh you're in a
different league like
i know that what it must have meant to
you to do that but i need to ask you
about peter rabbit before i run out of
time
um what no no please i i could talk
about that the entire time
um look out if you want to there's a
poster right there it's up to you
what do you think for people that aren't
familiar with how these movies are made
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of an animated
movie or the making of
peter rabbit um well i don't know if
they'd be surprised to learn but i can
tell you the thing that i was surprised
to learn which is
um when you do a film like this you
basically
for my my role in it is i record
the i tape the film probably maybe 25
times
from start to finish just keep going
back there's changes things like that
and then at the end of every day there's
a
about seven pages that look like this
and it's all
just uh noises expressions and
it is the hardest part of the entire
thing when you're just going like
or things like you know peter gets
knocked down stairs and you're going
and people are like yeah can you make it
a bit more like this and you
you go i why don't we do this at the
start when i'm really fresh they go
because you don't want your voice to go
because you're
shouting and screaming that's the thing
that i was surprised to learn there is a
whole
there must be hours and hours of footage
if just me making
ridiculous inaudible noises i know that
you co-wrote the cinderella movie
uh i didn't co-write it i didn't write
it no my bad
it's the thing that people have said but
that isn't i haven't
the film is the film is written and
directed
by kay cannon who people would know who
wrote the you know pitch perfect
movies um it's a
it's a it's a musical of cinderella
where as a father of young
daughters it just asks the question
that are perhaps our fairy tales
right for today's world should all of
our
female heroines in kids animation
or you know live action um be saved
necessarily by a prince and
maybe we could retell this story and
keep the traditional
core of it the story of what it is and
the romance of it and the joy of it
and maybe there's a world in which we
can make it that cinderella has some
different dreams some other dreams
and dreams that she might be able to
fulfill and i think kayla has done it
brilliantly we
merely uh ushered the the project
through
um but i i'm i'm so proud of her and
what she's done and camilla cabello is
outrageously good in this film steve
genuinely
she is like an absolute
star and a brilliant actor
i have to stop there i am very much
looking forward to it kay's a great
screenwriter
thank you so much for your time i could
talk to you all day
blessed you i mean that have a great day